A blood test showed an elevated BU end.
What does that mean?
Ah, okay.
So your BU end is your blood urea nitrogen.
It's a marker that reflects basically how you break, how you metabolize protein and it
really is looking at kidney function.
So urea is the primary component of the blood urea nitrogen that we're looking at here.
It's urea is formed in the liver and it's an end product of the breakdown of protein
in your body and then it's excreted in the kidney.
So that's why it's really a kidney marker.
So if you have elevated BU end levels, it can indicate, you know, issues with your kidney.
So it can indicate renal impairment.
It can indicate, you know, renal insufficiency, which means your, your kidneys are just
being stressed, long-term elevated blood urea nitrogen can indicate renal disease.
You can have an increase in BU end if you're dehydrated.
It's funny how a lot of markers will change with dehydration.
So if a person is dehydrated, certainly you're going to have an elevated BU end and it's
really because it's really a relative elevation of BU end because you have less fluid being
excreted.
Hypochloridria, meaning decreased stomach acid could elevate BU end.
That's another component somebody asked last week about using bicarbonate, whether it's
potassium bicarbonate or sodium bicarbonate, as a quote-unquote cancer treatment because
you'll see that in some old literature.
You'll see that in law, you know, some clinicians still advocate for that, which is ridiculous.
And some, a lot of people on the internet, you'll see that on the internet.
You don't believe everything you see on the internet.
Now, I can't tell you how many, you know, Facebook posts or videos that I see on the internet
that are just bulkers.
So I saw what I mentioned last week when somebody asked that question about bicarbonate.
And this is the cheapest medicine, no demand, simply take baking soda and put it in water
and drink it.
It's so good for helping stomach acid issues, so I'm about, it's like, oh my gosh, this
absolute ridiculousness.
That's what causes hypochloridria.
That's what's going to cause H. Pylori overgrowth and infections, cause a lot of diseases.
It's just harmful for you.
So hypochloridria can cause, can be another cause of elevated BU end.
Different diets can cause an elevation of BU end.
People on a card of war diet can have an elevated BU end.
That's one of the things that you have to look at on a card of war diet.
I'm not against using a card of war diet for somebody who has serious autoimmune disorders,
where a lot of people with serious autoimmune disorders have heavy damage to their gut and
in a lot of inflammation of their gut and they have hypersensitivity, they've developed antibodies
to a ton of different foods.
We've got a Cyrex tan on people with serious autoimmune diseases and it's not about
what they can't eat, it's about what they can't eat.
There's like five things that they can eat.
I mean, that's what I've seen Cyrex tan were out of, you know, 100 different things tested
for antibodies, literally 95 are positive.
It's like, all my worst, this guy's this person, typically that person has crows disease
or something like that and putting them on a card of war diet because many times it's
only meat that they can eat can be really helpful.
You've heard of different celebrities that have been healed from their autoimmune disease
being on a card of war diet.
They're actually able to calm things down and try to heal other things if they're not
having to deal with this fire in the gut.
But what you have to look at with those people is you have to keep an eye on their blood
urea nitrogen level because they're going to have excess protein consumption because it's
all they're consuming and they're breaking down this protein and that's what can cause
that.
Other things that can cause elevated mu and can be excess adrenal stress can cause
elevated mu and really damage cuts dysbiosis if you have really bad edema swelling, you
know, from something from, you know, a side ease can elevate your mu and then if you have
anterior protutor function dysfunction, you could have elevated BUN because you're just
not retaining things.
So there's a lot of things that can cause elevated mu and it depends on what else is going
on.
And remember, you don't just look at one marker, you look at one marker in conjunction with
other markers because okay, so if I have, if I'm suspected, I'm elevated BUN and could
it be hypochloridria?
Well, typically if you have elevated BUN and it increase an MCV and increase an MCH and
maybe a decrease or normal calcium, a decreased iron, a decreased alkaline phosphatase, a decreased
chloride, then you'd suspect more so that it's caused from hypochloridria.
But you're also going to look at not just in comparison to other markers, you have to
look at it in comparison to what's going on in that person's light.
So if they have an elevated BUN and they're taking a medication, let's say, Ben Ben or
Ivermectin, then you have to, you know, if you're putting on your Sherlock home hat here,
you have to investigate all the possible causes of this change in marker level and that's
how you come to a working diagnosis.
So if nothing else changes in this person's life, it was a normal BUN four months ago and
now they started taking this medication and now it's elevated.
Okay, well, you know, we're going to rule things out.
It's quite possible.
It's from this medication, maybe we should reduce that and see if that changes it.
So that's how you come to, you know, answer a question like that blood test showed
an elevated BUN, what does that be?